[Musique]
notre maison nous regardons ailleurs
bienvenue dans présage le podcast qui
questionne l'état de notre monde
les risques d'effondrement de notre
civilisation industrielle et les façons
de se préparer à vivre différemment je
suis alexis à soyaux et aujourd'hui je
reçois jean marc jancovici
on peut être pessimiste en l'analyse et
optimisant l'action ingénieur
polytechnicien spécialiste des questions
d'énergie et du climat jean marc
jancovici est réputé pour son franc
parler et il ne plaît pas à tourner
est-ce qu'il est encore temps de
maintenir le système en l'état à la
réponse est on moi j'ai jamais cru une
seule seconde que les hommes n'étaient
que des agents économiques rationnelle
maximisant leur revenu chez pas pourquoi
on continue à enseigner cette connerie
sans nom en cours d'économie
j'étais extrêmement curieuse d'en savoir
un peu plus sur lui sur sa vision du
monde qui vient et sur son engagement à
répéter sans lassitude
au fil de ses innombrables conférences
ses articles et ses livres le lien entre
énergie climat pib montée des populismes
durant une heure nous avons pas et tout
ça et de bien d'autres choses
il ya des choses auxquelles je suis
toujours pas préparé par exemple la
privation de liberté bonjour jean marc
jancovici jours
vous êtes ingénieur fondateur du cabinet
carbone 4 confondateur cofondateur par
non vous êtes reconnu pour votre
expertise des problématiques climatiques
et énergétiques
c'est ce que dit wikipedia c'est ce que
dit wikipedia et depuis
un petit moment où fait un gros travail
de vulgarisation via votre site internet
et vos livres et des conférences que
vous donnez de puis voilà non je
voudrais d'abord savoir comment est ce
que vous avez commencé à vous intéresser
à ces problématiques de l'énergie et du
changement climatique par hasard en fait
ça a été un ça a été un fait du hasard
le dans les années 90 90
mon métier consiste concernaient
essentiellement l'informatique et des
télécoms
et à cette époque là orange qui ne
s'appelait pas encore angers qui
s'appelait france télécom avait commencé
à voir pointer tout ce qui était télé
quelque chose
c'est l'époque où il ya commencé à voir
une grande effervescence dans
l'effervescence pardon sur le potentiel
de la télémédecine du télétravail du
tennis aussi du télé cela et france
télécom avaient demandé à la société
avec laquelle je travaillais de faire
tout a pas de business plan sur le
potentiel de ces nouvelles modalités de
travail ou d'organisation et puis quand
on fait en regardant ça d'un peu près il
ya quelque chose qui a commencé à
arriver dans les raisonnements qui était
tout ce qui était les quelque chose
permet d'éviter des déplacements
enfin en théorie voilà quand la la la
l'observation des faits montrent que
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça remet
permet normalement d'éviter des
déplacements et en évitant des
déplacements disait la littérature à
laquelle j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
la question on évitait des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre donc là on est au
milieu des années 90 je ne connais
strictement rien à la question du
changement climatique
encore moins à quoi que ce soit aux
questions énergétiques et je vois
arriver ce truc avec effet de serre lui
tient dès qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc là donc je commence à regarder
je regarde un peu constate que je n'y
comprends strictement rien et donc j'ai
fait à ce moment ce que font un certain
nombre de gens qui sont énervés par le
fait de rien y comprendre
j'ai souhaité me documenter et à
l'époque se documenter en lisant des
livres etc
c'était compliqué parce qu'il n'y avait
pas beaucoup de livres de vulgarisation
sur la question et à ce moment je j'ai
proposé au groupe environnement de mon
association d'anciens élèves de monter
une série de conférences sur la question
et pour non pas les conférences pour les
données puisque à l'époque j'étais bien
là capable de le faire mais en faisant
intervenir des gens qui allaient venir
nous expliquer de quoi il retournait
quand on parlait de changement
climatique et à cette époque là c'était
une époque bénie où quand on envoyait un
mail à hervé le treut tout à jean jouzel
en leur disant là il ya un truc que j'ai
pas compris est ce que vous pourriez
venir m'expliquer il répondait dans le
quart d'heure
et si on leur proposait de venir faire
une conférence devant un groupe de 15
personnes vous disais oui voilà et donc
c'est exactement comme ça que j'ai fait
ma formation sur le sujet c'est à dire
que j'ai commencé par organiser pour
ceux qui n'y comprenaient rien de moi
parce qu'en général on est toujours
intéressé à se servir en premier dans ce
genre d'organisation une série de
conférences sur la question du
changement climatique alors ça c'est la
fin des années 90 et après avoir bien
bien compris le tour du problème je me
suis dit ah ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus intéressant puisque je
suis en ce moment c'est ça que j'ai
envie de faire quand je serai grand
après quoi j'avais toujours donc là
j'avais à l'époque j'étais consultant
indépendant donc le france télécom je
travaillais pour eux indirectement au
travers d'une société dont j'étais sous
traitants j'étais pas mais en rouge
avait quand même beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre sur l'organisation de mon
temps et comme j'étais dans un domaine
qui était très concurrentiel j'étais pas
occupé de 8 heures du matin à 10 heures
le soir comme c'est parfois un peu trop
souvent le cas aujourd'hui et donc le et
donc je gère le j'ai le temps de faire
ma formation
après cette série de conférences je me
lit l'intégralité du rapport du giec du
banc donc celui de 1995 et je me dis je
vais essayer d'en faire ma vie
professionnelle et c'est à ce moment là
que j'ai eu l'idée au cours d'une
conférence donnée par d'autres personnes
de ce qui allait devenir le bilan
carbone alors j'avais une idée mais pas
de clients donc j'ai regardé qui pouvait
éventuellement payer développement de ce
truc là avant ça n'existe pas van persie
de mesurer
si il commençait à y avoir des
initiatives et en particulier les
anglais avaient publié dès le milieu des
années 90 quelque chose qu'on pourrait
qualifier comme l'ancêtre du bilan
carbone c'est-à-dire un guide à
destination des entreprises pour en
calculer une partie des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de leur chaîne de
valeur mais une partie seulement
mais ça je m'en suis rendu compte après
avoir commencé à travailler sur le sujet
donc à l'époque je me dis il faut
absolument mettre au point un outil qui
permettent aux entreprises de comprendre
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui sont la contrepartie des processus
dont elles dépendent et il faut
organiser sa part processus il faut pas
l'organiser en fonction de ces chez moi
ou c'est pas chez moi
il faut l'organiser en fonction de qui a
la main sur l'organisation du processus
dans toutes les entreprises avaient un
responsable de la logistique parra dès
lors que vous transporter des
marchandises le fait que les camions
soient vous pas à vous c'est un
déterminant second le déterminant
premier c'est la nature de ce que vous
avez à transporter là où sont les usines
et ça où sont les consommateurs voilà
donc il y a un objet donc l'idée du
bilan carbone n'est à ce moment là et
j'ai l'immense chance de trouver sur mon
chemin un homme qui s'appelle jean
pierre thabet qui travaillait à l'ademe
à l'époque où il était le chef du
service économique
mais tout en étant docteur en physique
et qui est le seul type de l'ademe le
sol vraiment qu'ils étaient capables de
dire oui un type qui arrive avec la
gueule enfarinée en lui disant j'ai une
idée j'y connais rien mais voilà l'idée
que j'ai et qui est capable de lui dire
du banco on va travailler ensemble sur
l'idée il y en avait pas de à l'ademe à
mon avis capable de faire de faire ça et
j'ai eu l'immense chance de tomber sur
lui donc je proposais l'ademe ce
qu'allait devenir le bilan carbone et
après j'ai envie de dire l'histoire a
fait le reste c'est à dire que j'ai été
le premier bord du royaume des aveugles
et ça et ça a fait l'essor de la
carrière professionnelle
parallèlement parce que ça a été un
processus parallèle la série de
conférences que j'avais organisé donc
pour le compte de la l'association et
ancien de la ville x
donne lieu à un numéro spécial de la
revue des anciens élèves sur le
changement climatique dans lequel je
rédige un long article de synthèse des
conférences en question essai remarqué
par un ami dominique bourg qui était
éditeur au seuil à l'époque et qui me
dit oh mais ça ça a l'air très
intéressant est ce que tu voudrais pas
écrire un livre
là aussi j'ai eu la chance de trouver
quelqu'un qui a misé sur moi il a même
misé sur moi alors que j'étais jeune
jeunes auteurs n'ayant jamais écrit deux
livres il a accepté de verser une avance
sur recette un avaloir et j'ai écrit
ainsi mon premier livre s'appelle avenir
climatique qui paru en 2002 ou 2003 je
me souviens déjà plus et qui lui a fait
le début deux entre guillemets ma
carrière de vulgarisateur parce qu'un
livre ça peut rendre visible aux yeux
des médias et donc voilà donc j'ai
commencé à avoir quelques passages dans
les médias à cause de ce livre et les
demandes de conférences derrière qui ont
suivi mais c était de processus
parallèle c'est à dire que ce qui a fait
ma carrière professionnelle s'est
développée raisonnablement
indépendamment de ce qui a fait ma
carrière de vulgarisateur entre
guillemets et de très modestes écrivain
ça a été deux processus parallèles puis
vous avez fait combien de conférence
pour 700 ou 800 enfin si je mets
boutabout les conférences et les
formations une formation fly conférence
n'étant rien d'autre une formation pour
révision personnes je dois en être à 7
ou 800 et du coup là où je voulais en
venir c'est qu'est ce que ça fait de
travailler depuis aussi longtemps sur
ces sujets nous travailler sur ces
sujets et de d'essayer de répandre la
pas forcément la bonne parole mais là la
connaissance juste et de voir qu'il n'y
a pas grand chose qui change ou ou que
ça va peut-être un peu pire qu'avant
quoi est ce que il ya plusieurs manières
de répondre à ça d'abord une précision
c'est que quand je regarde de ce que je
faisais comme conférence en 2002 est ce
que je fais aujourd'hui c'est quand même
pas exactement pareil d'abord pour une
raison tout simplement technique c'est
qu'en 2002 le vidéoprojecteur était un
truc qui était beaucoup plus rare
qu'aujourd'hui et donc à l'époque les
conférences je les faisais avec des
supports sur transparent donc les plus
jeunes qui vont nous écouter ils ne
savent même pas qu'il ya eu une époque
où le monde n'avait pas de vidéo
projecteurs n'avez pas internet n'avez
pas de smartphone et n'avait pas ce
match at ce qui est quand même vraiment
on n'ose même pas imaginer mais et donc
on avait donc un vidéoprojecteur un
rétroprojecteur pardon ça projeter une
image fixe donc je me baladais avec mon
paquet de mon paquet de transparent
qu'il y en avait 200 ou 300 et puis je
piocher dedans à la volée en fonction
des publics que j'avais en face de moi à
l'époque je racontais pas la même chose
qu'aujourd'hui
par exemple quand j'ai commencé à faire
mes conférences le lien énergie économie
je l'avais pas du tout en fait
enfin je l'avais centrale aujourd'hui
ces centrales je l'avais pas en tête
j'avais pas compris finalement à quel
point vouloir régler le problème du
changement climatique c'était en gros
vouloir délibérément contracté
l'économie donc le jeu racontait pas les
mêmes choses tous ces domaines
techniques
donc le changement climatique en est un
il y en a plein d'autres sont
aujourd'hui des domaines dans lesquels
on apprend à tout âge je veux dire
encore aujourd'hui j'apprends des choses
que je ne savais pas donc le donc sa
housse en fait on on a l'impression que
je fais toujours la même conférence
peut-être vu de l'extérieur moi j'ai pas
l'impression de faire la même je parle
d'un sujet qui est globalement le même
ça c'est clair que je me suis pas mis à
parler de la façon de faire de la
décoration d'intérieur et guérido mais
par contre je ne parle pas de la même
façon de ce sujet je met pas l'accent
sur les mêmes points saillants je n'ai
pas la même façon de vulgariser les
choses voilà on peut on peut trouver des
astuces au fur et à mesure la deuxième
chose qui fait que ses fins le deuxième
élément qui fait qu on ne se répètent ce
qu à moitié c'est que à chaque fois que
le public change
vous avez une partie des questions qui
sont pas les mêmes
donc il ya des questions qui sont
toujours les mêmes je peux vous dire y'a
pas une conférence qui se termine sans
que j'ai droit à la question qui est que
fait la police c'est à dire que font les
politiques ce qui est très propre à la
france parce que comme on considère que
le chef de l'état c'est à la fois notre
part un notre père dieu
le roi etc etc il est chargé de prendre
sous son aile protectrice
quand il ya un camp tient à danger
quelques pas on dira où il est le
protectrice et que foule en prier terre
de l'ale protectrice voilà on oublie un
peu trop que c'est aussi à nous de nous
prendre en charge mais il ya d'autres
questions qui évolue avec le temps ça
c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
thermomètre
je me rappelle par exemple que dans mes
qu'on fait dans les conférences que je
faisais ya 15 ans en général
j'avais j'avais droit dans les questions
à deux et je veux dire deux catégories
d'emmerdeur pour être un peu les pieds
dans le plat les climato sceptiques et
les anti nucléaires ce qui soit dit en
passant sont deux catégories d'emmerdeur
qui vis-à-vis de la science se comporte
exactement de la même manière les
climato-sceptiques ni la science
climatique les anti nucléaires ni le
corpus scientifique dont on dispose sur
le nucléaire
voilà même type de comportement et dans
un cas comme dans l'autre
en fait ils illustrent cette maxime des
indésirables là que j'aime beaucoup le
connaissent et les indésirables degorce
il ya une planche de bord sur laquelle
vous voyez un pingouin dire à l'autre
les faits sont violemment démenti par
mon opinion c'est exactement ça le
climato-scepticisme comme le nucléaire
comme l'anti nucléariste obéissent à 7,7
quant au printemps quand on compare la
science est là et là il a eu l'idée que
les gens s'enfoncer en tout cas donc
j'avais droit à 100 et puis maintenant
j'ai droit à des questions qui ne sont
plus du tout de cette nature en général
les questions sont essentiellement sur
terrain de l'action
comment on arrive à avancer la la la
difficulté à laquelle on se heurte
aujourd'hui n'est plus de croire les
faits elle est d'arriver à prendre
conscience du fait que au fond régler le
problème du changement climatique c'est
accepter de se confronter à une limite
et que de se confronter à une limite est
un truc dont on a horreur puisque toute
l'action humaine ever depuis que les
hommes existent c'est au contraire
d'essayer de dépasser les limites
plus haut plus loin rappeler la devise
des jeux olympiques un site us altius
fortius enfin joueurs globalement la le
passé il faut dire le destin ou le
l'envi profonde des hommes c'est de
faire plus que ce qu'ils faisaient avant
faire moins on sait pas faire or le
changement climatique c'est faire - donc
le faut régler le problème du changement
climatique de manière délibérée
c'est faire moins donc oui je je je pars
toujours une forme de tronc commun et
encore j'ai pas toujours la même manière
de rentrer dans le problème par contre
la façon dont ça évolue derrière et
quand même quelque chose qui a beaucoup
bougé en 15 ans est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas comme un peu je sais pas c est ce
que vous êtes désespérément vides et
l'inaction non mais j'ai écrit un jour
que le fait d'être optimiste ou
pessimiste était pas une affaire de
situation c'est une affaire de code
génétique c'est-à-dire que vous avez des
gens qui passent leur journée tout
depuis tout petit à ronchonner à se
plaindre et à considérer que tout va de
travers et à se laisser porter par les
événements et puis vous avez des gens
qui depuis tout petit crois qu'ils vont
bouffer la terre entière
même si manifestement ils n'y arriveront
pas et même si manifestement le bateau
coule donc l'optimisme c'est pas une
affaire d' analyse rationnelle de la
situation c'est une affaire de gènes une
affaire de personnalité et l'optimiste
il a souvent une caractérise dans
l'action parce qu'on peut être
pessimiste dans l'analyse et optimisant
l'action s'appelle quelque part une
forme de cynisme
non non mais j'assume il m'arrive de
temps en temps d'être cynique 1 ou
caustiques variantes d'une rien du
cynisme mais le l'optimiste il a cette
caractéristique que souvent il
entreprend et que la réussite de sa
petite entreprise peut suffire à lui
amener le baume au coeur qui va bien
dans un monde qui par ailleurs
n'évoluent pas comme ils souhaiteraient
que ça évolue
et moi je suis exactement dans cette
situation dire par rapport à tous les
gens qui reçoivent le message que je
leur envoie en pleine figure en disant
oui à iai
qu'est ce qui va m'arriver moi j'ai la
chance d'être déjà dans l'action et
d'avoir déjà dans l'action des
indicateurs qui vont dans le sens de
quelque chose qui est sympathique
alors je vais prendre deux exemples en
2007 avec alain grandjean on a fondé un
cabinet de conseil qui s'appelle carbone
4 quand on a fondé le cabinet de conseil
et on était deux associés et deux
employés à mi-temps
aujourd'hui on est 35 et comme chacun
sait à chacun sa croissance sans bon
c'est pas avec 35 personnes qu'on va
sauver le monde ça c'est clair
comme je le dis souvent à mes employés
le propre de carbone 4 c'est d'être une
société à durée limitée puisque dès
qu'on a réglé le pari du changement
climatique en dise où la société
mais je n'ai aucune inquiétude quant au
fait que les gens qui auront contribué à
sauver le monde trouveront très
facilement inscrire employés ailleurs
j'ai pas beaucoup de doute là dessus
donc mais mais à court terme on en est
on y est pas encore et donc ça par
exemple c'est la marque quand même d'une
forme de crédibilité qui augmente parce
que si les entreprises acceptent de
donner plus d'argent c'est quand même
quelque part que ce dont on s'occupe à
plus de valeur pour elle que l imminence
d
et des chocs et plus proches qua non
mais donc ça réseau à leur voix la plus
plus l'environnement et risquer plus
votre prime d'assurance à la valeur donc
ou plus vous acceptez de la payer donc
voilà donc à côté de ça j'ai monté le
shift qui là aussi pour le moment est
encore vivant après sept ans d'existence
dont bon quand même raisonnablement
content on a monté à côté de ça on a
aidé gaël a monté sa chaire énergie et
prospérité qui est aussi toujours
vivante et qui croît et embellit donc
quand on regarde un certain nombre de
graines qu'on a planté il ya maintenant
dix ou quinze ans il y en a quand même
une partie qui ont germé et donner des
plantes
alors encore une fois ces plantes sont
pas suffisantes pour oxygéner
l'atmosphère au bon niveau si je
continuais dans le parallèle mais ça ça
fait partie des choses qui permettent de
ne pas désespérer billancourt
c'est à dire que dans un monde où
effectivement globalement les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre augmentent la
température augmente le nombre de
catastrophes imputable au climat
augmenté c'est que le début la détresse
liée au stress énergétique dans l' ocde
augmente quoi qu'on en dise sur le
retour de la croissance qu'à regarder le
nombre de sans abri dans paris et la
vitesse à laquelle ça augmente
voilà il ya tout un tas de trucs qui
évolue dans la mauvaise direction mais
très égoïstement à mon petit niveau
il ya des marqueurs de l'action du sujet
dans lequel je suis qui sont plus que du
baume au coeur c'est à dire qu'il ya des
choses que l'ambiance au sein de carbone
4 est très dynamique parce que c'est une
bande de jeunes
heureusement qu'on est là les associés
pour mettre une moyenne d'âge à peu près
correct parce que sinon c'est vraiment
c'est l'école maternelle dont je
présente mais quand même une bande de
jeunes ça a un côté très très revigorant
très vivifiant de se retrouver dans
cette ambiance où les jours donc voilà
donc il ya des il ya des éléments on va
dire ben hauteurs d'ans
petit univers personnels égoïstes qui
font que non seulement on peut avoir le
code génétique qui incite à l'action
mais on peut en avoir la récompense dans
son univers immédiat après c'est clair
qu'une analyse rationnelle de la
situation montre que le ciel est plutôt
en train de se durcir
et justement on entend des choses un peu
différentes
il sera bientôt trop tard pour on ne
sait pas quoi exactement
on a trois ans pour agir je pensais à ça
j'ai entendu le le plan 1000 milliards
pour le climat dont on dit qu on a trois
ans pour agir
je comprend pas exactement on a trois
ans pour agir avant quoi ou alors on
entend aussi on a 20 ans pour sauver le
monde en gros et donc voilà qu'est ce
que vous pensez vous de ça on a combien
de temps pour agir et pour sauver quoi
exactement
alors si le silo but du jeu c'est de
maintenir une humanité à quelques
milliards d'individus avec une espérance
de vie à 70 ans à la naissance pour les
siècles qui viennent c'est déjà trop
tard
si le but du jeu c'est de maintenir des
hommes quel que soit leur nombre en
quantité suffisante pour qu'ils puissent
se reproduire avec l'espèce survive il
sera jamais trop tard parce qu on a une
espèce tellement ubiquiste que
ouais on est des morpions s'accroche
partout enfin je veux dire quand on voit
que les eskimos ont réussi à survivre
sans pétrole sans charbon sans gaz avec
des phoques et les igloos enfin je veux
dire voilà on a une espèce tellement
adaptable temps qu'il reste 3 3 animaux
à bouffer il restera des hommes quelque
part mais est ce qu'il en restera à 5
milliards 500 millions ou 5 millions ça
j'en sais rien du tout et en fait ce
dont je suis totalement persuadé c'est
que à l'échéance du siècle il n'en
restera pas 5 milliards vivent comme
dans les conditions de vie d'un français
ordinaire c'est absolument certain d'un
français ordinaires d'aujourd'hui vous
parlez quand même de l'échéance du socle
oui parce que je sais pas alors c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire de
l'attribution des co alors le problème
d'une expérience qu'on fait pour la
première fois ce qui est le cas de
changer massivement le climat et de deux
je pas quelqu'un français de déplétés
enfin de 2,2 de supprimer on va dire
d'amenuiser voilà rapidement les
ressources non renouvelables dont on
dépend par ailleurs toute notre
civilisation est basée sur le fait que
l'on peut puiser dans la nature des
minerais métalliques du pétrole des
pierres de carrière etc
tout ça c'est des ressources non
renouvelables donc on a à l'amont tout
un système qui dépend de ressources non
renouvelables à laval tout une épuration
de nos déchets qui est basé sur le
postulat que le monde est tellement
vaste qu'on peut mettre ce qu'on veut
dans il reste stable
les deux postulats sont faux
et donc plus on attend et plus tout ça
va être déstabilisés mais c'est mais on
ne comprend comment ça s'est passé que
ex post
tout simplement parce que quand on fait
une expérience pour la première fois il
ya plein de conséquence qu'on n'est pas
capable de prédire avec finesse à
l'avance dans mon dernier bouquin
j'explique par exemple que le printemps
arabe à un déterminant énergie climat
majeur j'aurais jamais été capable de le
prédire
donc je suis capable de proposer cette
théorie une fois que ça s'est passé mais
personne alors et maintenant du reste
par effet de reproduction je suis
capable de dire quels pays sont à risque
à l'avenir à cause exactement des mêmes
causes je vais vous dire l'algérie je
peux vous dire le mexique je peux vous
dire le venezuela
enfin voilà il ya un certain nombre de
pays qui sont mais mais mais je suis pas
que j'aurais pas été capable avant ce
qui s'est passé au moment du printemps
arabe de faire une prédiction fine donc
le le problème de cette double
contrainte de la contrainte de la
finitude du monde en gros face à une
humanité qui ne cherchent qu'à croître
et embellir c'est que là où les
craquements vont s'appliquer
vous n'êtes pas capable de le prédire de
manière fine donc c'est comme la
tectonique des plaques
vous êtes capable de dire que la
probabilité écueil est pas un
tremblement de terre en californie dans
le million d'années qui vient est
rigoureusement nul
par contre est-ce que vous êtes capable
de dire que ça va avoir lieu dans cinq
ans dans 10 ans 20 ans dans 50 ans non
est ce que vous êtes capable de dire que
plus on attend et plus la probabilité
que ce soit violents augmente sa wii
donc là c'est pareil plus le monde
cherche à résister à la contraction qui
finira par arriver à court terme peut
pas non plus fini par ray puis cherche à
résister à court terme à la contraction
qui finira par arriver et plus les
mécanismes de contractions ont toutes
les chances d'être violent et très
désagréable bon ça c'est voilà un
exemple idiot enfin ou faciles à
comprendre mais mais une fois qu'on a
dit ça
personne ne sait dire le mur
il est à tel moment c'est une vision
très binaire le mur en gros c'est avant
vous êtes vivants après vous êtes mort
donc avant il ya une humanité aprilia
n'a plus avant c'est quoi le mur
exactement bon voilà donc en fait il n'y
a pas vraiment de mur il ya il ya une
augmentation graduelle
de la pression à laquelle ont sauvé le
système et donc de la probabilité qu'ils
réagissent plutôt plus vite et plus tôt
plus violemment à la pression en
question donc pour répondre à la
question initiale
est-ce qu'il est encore temps de
maintenir le système en l'état à la
réponse est non est-ce qu'il est trop
tard pour éviter la guerre
thermonucléaire plus la porte débit plus
etc
je n'en sais rien tout ce que je sais
c'est que plus on attend et plus la
probabilité augmente et ce dont je suis
sûr aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a trop
attendu pour éviter des grosses baffes
donc de toute façon il y aura les
grosses claques
ça c'est sûr partout mais ces grosses
claques peuvent passer par des chemins
en apparence détourné pour les gens qui
connaissent pas bien le problème qui
s'appelle le vote populiste et moi
j'explique dans mon dernier bouquin
aussi en quoi c'est très lié à la créa
la question énergétique et c'est pas
géopolitique c'est à cause de son
physique
ça peut passer par des implosions
politique ça peut passer enfin jouer et
ça passera par pas par des processus de
cette nature ce qui veut dire en plus
que au moment où ça commencera à se
manifester
il y aura une erreur sur l'attribution
des causes c'est à dire qu'on verra la
cause là où elle n'est pas et du coup il
ya toutes les chances pour que les
premières tentatives de réponses aux
problèmes n'y changent rien voir la
grave là aussi je donne quelques
exemples de sujets dans lequel
aujourd'hui on est en train de dépenser
notre argent pour régler les problèmes
qui n'existent pas et se faisant par
effet d'éviction on ne dépense pas pour
rien les problèmes qui existent vraiment
comment est-ce que votre parole et
reçues auprès des des dirigeants
d'entreprise et des politiques alors ma
parole et reçus ont dirigé au niveau des
dirigeants d'entreprise suffisamment
pour faire vivre une société qui fait
quelques millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires mais qui n'en fait pas
quelques milliards
[Musique]
donc ça donne quand même la mesure de la
du fait que le problème reste limité
aujourd'hui si je si je donne une
échelle rapide le plus grand cabinet
d'expertise-comptable au monde donc l'un
des big for fait deux cent cinquante
mille personnes
donc pour compter les euros les
entreprises acceptent de faire vivre un
certain nombre de monstres qui ont deux
cent cinquante mille personnes
donc ça doit vouloir dire à vue de nez
30 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires vous voyez 30 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires versus
carbone 4 qui en fait 3 millions vous
avez un rapport de 1 à 10 milles entre
les moyens que les entreprises acceptent
de mettre dans le fait de compter les
euros et le fait qu'elle ait les moyens
qu'elles acceptent de mettre dans le
fait de courir carbone qui est la base
de tout quand on veut agir donc très
raisonnablement
la réponse pessimiste à la question qui
vient d'être posée c'est elles reçoivent
mais ça change pas grand chose
est ce qu'il ya des des déchets
l'entreprise qui ont qui ont
radicalement changé de nom il y en a qui
disent qu'ils vont radicalement changer
mais quand on regarde dans les fêtes
entre maintenant et à 15 ans on n'y a
pas de différence donc enfin il n'y a
pas de différence de ya pas de rupture
faut quand même voir que les entreprises
et c'est à ça que servent les services
comme
leur première envie c'est de manipuler
la presse comme tous les mouvements
militants moi compris soit dit en
passant
bah oui si la presse était non
manipulable
il y aurait pas de service communication
les journalistes trouverait tout seul de
quoi ils doivent parler ferait de vraies
investigations au lieu de recevoir des
communiqués de presse et des transformer
en article c'est un peu méchant ce que
je suis en train de dire vers l'abattoir
dont fonctionne la presse c'est
exactement ça et donc les joueurs mais
quand vous dites aux journalistes que il
participe trop souvent une vaste
entreprise de manipulation ils vous
disent que non non non ils ont puni sont
parfaitement compétents qui savent de
quoi il veut en phase est la meilleure
preuve en baisse et que si c'était faux
ce que je disais tous les médias
parlerais pas des mêmes sujets au même
moment fait qu'il parle tous des mêmes
sujets obèses blanc ça montre bien qu'il
ya un émetteur unique qui a parlé plus
fort que les autres et à ce moment là
ils sont tous emparé du sujet donc le
pour faire passer dans les médias le
message comme quoi ils ont bien compris
que c'était un problème est qu'ils vont
s'en occuper
là il n'y a pas de sujet
quelques le message est passé pareil
dans le monde politique mais une fois
qu'on a passé le stade des discours
souvent on est encore très très loin des
mouvements de fonds qui permettent
d'avancer sur le sujet dit autrement
aujourd'hui des entreprises qui disent
très bien je vais nommer un monsieur
carbone il va être à droite du président
il aura autorité pour réfuter tous les
plans industriel de tous les patrons de
business unit qui veut 10 temps chez
carrefour que chez saint gobain ou chez
vous chez schneider ou chez airbus
je vais tout passés à la paille de fer
du compatibilité avec une trajectoire de
deux années ça existe pas nulle part
jamais j'ai pas vu ça une seule fois
dans ma vie je connais en france dans
les clients de carbone 4 nous avons
aujourd'hui un directeur de la stratégie
un qui est un mec sérieux mais le
rendant là hein donc c'est juste pour
dire alors que directeur de la stratégie
en france gérard des milliers donc cessé
et on est capable de le servir cette
table à 1 il nous a même avoué un jour
en rigolant qu'il était très content
d'avoir bossé avec nous parce que on lui
avait fait pour dix fois moins cher et
mieux ce que mc kids est lui aurait fait
pour dix fois plus cher et moins bien
mais mais c'est juste pour dire on
aujourd'hui il y à il ya big tox cause
pour l'actionnaire on est on est on est
vraiment dans un contexte dans lequel il
ya trois ordres de grandeur entre le
discours et la finance va être verte
c'est merveilleux etc
croit que la croissance va être verte
machin on va tout va et vert je rappelle
que vers c'est aussi quand on a digéré
un truc de travers et qu'on s'apprête à
dégueuler avant donc le voilà donc cessé
mais c'est ça aujourd'hui la situation
ce qui a quand même changé donc là ça
c'était la partie verre à moitié vide
la partie verre à moitié plein c'est que
aujourd'hui le discours que je porte
il y à une demande très fortement
croissante pour venir le porter dans les
entreprises c'est à dire que j'ai pas
qu'on n'est pas encore au stade où les
gens acceptent de faim ou les dirigeants
entreprises acceptent de payer très cher
pour commencer à avoir des une vraie
action de lobbying pour qu'on s'occupe
du sujet sauf certains et une vraie
envie de dépenser des dizaines de
millions pour réfléchir à la façon dont
ils vont reconfigurer leurs activités
pour essayer de passer un peu mieux la
rampe d'accord
par contre on en est maintenant au stade
qui n'existait pas il ya 15 ans ou dans
à peu près toutes entreprises il ya
quelques alliés qui veulent que des gens
comme moi à y parler au comex
c'est ça la situation qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises et j'ai
assez souvent des demandes
d'interventions en fait quand je regarde
parce que je veux un ingénieur savez les
statistiques donc quand je regarde à qui
j'ai causé pendant mes 800 conférence en
question donc j'ai fait une petite
nomenclature et donc j'ai les gens dans
les milieux économiques
donc ça c'est quand je vais faire une
conférence à l'intérieur d'une
entreprise ou pour une chambre de
commerce ou pour une fédération
professionnelle ou à l'occasion d'un
salon économique ou etc
ça sera dans l'économique j'ai les
conférences que j'ai fait pour les hauts
fonctionnaires les conférences que j'ai
fait pour des audiences strictement
politique des assemblées d'élus etc
les conférences que j'ai fait pour des
journalistes en formation donc pas des
gens qui viennent m'interviewer des
journalistes en formation qui veulent
comprendre c'est bien savoir les
proportions
en gros et les interventions que j'ai
fait qui relève de la formation mes
cours à l'école des mines plus toutes
les conférences que je peux faire dans
des écoles d'ingénieurs non dans les
écoles d'ingénieurs dans les lycées
beaucoup plus rarement dans les facs et
c est dans les labos de recherche
la moitié des interventions c'est le
monde économique
un quart de mes interventions ses
enseignements et recherches et grand
public fonctionnaires médias politiques
se partagent le quart restant politique
ça doit être un pur sang là dedans je
compte les auditions à l'assemblée
nationale par exemple le les hauts
fonctionnaires ces quelques pourcents le
grand public ça doit être 10 % sachant
quand je fais une conférence grand
public en fait c'est toujours les mêmes
qui il ya d'écouter la messe 1 donc
voila en gros quel est la typologie de
mes interventions donc donc le côté
positif de la faire encore une fois
c'est que la moitié de mes interventions
sont faites dans des enceintes où il ya
des gens comme le dit un de mes amis qui
peuvent quelque chose du coup sûr c'est
l'idée de l'absurdité de la croissance
verte qu'enfin quand vous dites un peu à
tout le monde que la croissance ne
reviendra pas et que la croissance verte
est un non sens est-ce que parfois vous
êtes enfin vous entré en conflit avec
des gens qui ne veulent pas entendre ce
que vous dites les gens qui veulent pas
entendre ce que dit il m'invite pas donc
évidemment que je rentre en conflit avec
potentiellement avec plein de gens mais
je les vois pas encore une fois on ne
prête qu'aux riches
donc quand on me demande de faire une
conférence c'est toujours quelqu'un qui
a déjà entendu ce que je racontais la
personne qui dit ok a toujours quand
même une vague idée
de ce qui va se passer donc il n'ya pas
deux il ya peu de surprises
et puis par ailleurs le fait que la
croissance va avec la croissance des
flux et la croissance économique qui va
avec la croissance des flux physiques et
que la croissance des flux physiques
advitam eternam est pas compatible avec
un monde fini il ya même les gens qui
n'en avaient pas conscience dans une
salle de conférence
il y en a peut-être beaucoup y en a
probablement beaucoup pour trouver ça
désagréable
il y en a très peu pour me rentrer
dedans en me disant banon vous venez de
raconter une connerie alors là où les
gens peuvent commencer à montrer de
danser mais on peut faire de la
croissance qualitative la connaissance
et l'économie de la connaissance etc
auquel cas je le redis c'est
partiellement vrai mais c'est très très
partiel parce que remplacer le fait
d'avoir un toit par un logiciel je pense
que si vous demandez aux sans abri que
vous voyez dans paris est ce qu'ils sont
d'accord pour faire de l'économie de la
connaissance à la place du fait d'avoir
un toit qui lui demande du béton et de
l'acier pas complètement persuadés
qu'ils vont vous dire oui non du coup
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'espèce de
schizophrénie qui ya entre une partie du
monde qui perd technophiles et qui
chercha à résoudre tous par l'innovation
qui cherchent à augmenter l'homme qui
cherche à coloniser mars et c est la
réalité des enjeux et de la situation
les inégalités qui sait tous et tous ses
délires technophiles en fait sont le
fait de cadres urbains protéger des
vicissitudes de la vie
en fait ces décès des envies de gamin
les premiers gamins et temps les
californiens parce que les américains
sont des grands enfants
c'est les plus grands enfants de la
terre voilà donc une fois que le
californien il a
quelques dizaines ou centaines de
millions sur son compte en banque que
enfin voilà qu'il a tout pas de problème
que seul truc qui lui manque c'est
d'être immortel donc ils cherchent à
être immortel et comme les états unis
sont un pays prédateur par excellence
c'est à dire c'est le pays qui accueille
impôts ces inventions reste du monde par
un système prédateur à la fois sur les
cervelles et sur les sur le droit de
propriété bas derrière ça diffuse dans
le reste du monde
et comme les français de temps en temps
n'oublie pas d'être con il a passé 13
c'est très intelligent c'est très malin
on va faire la même chose donc on est un
peuple de suivre aujourd'hui c'est très
clair on a beau se gargariser essayer de
retrouver grandeur gaullienne etc
on est en fait en pratique macro le
premier macron son amour de la tech est
un amour de suiveurs c'est pas un amour
de précurseur donc voilà donc le dock
dont alors le rêve risque il n'ya de
tout régler par la technique
c'est le résultat de deux siècles
d'histoire
jusqu'à il ya deux siècles c'est à dire
jusqu à l'essor des machines mû par les
combustibles fossiles parce que quand on
dit l'essor des combustibles fossiles en
fait c'est l'essor des convertisseurs mû
par les combustibles fossiles des
machines et donc la machine à vapeur et
le moteur à combustion interne pui loin
derrière un puits loin derrière dans
l'histoire le moteur électrique mais le
l'histoire de la révolution industrielle
c'est l'histoire de la découverte de
nouveaux convertisseurs qu'on a réussi à
alimenter avec des sources d'énergie
surpuissante que le corps humain ne
s'est pas exploité en direct si vous
buvez du pétrole ça vous permet pas de
folies et ça vous permet pas d'avancer à
100 km/heure même pas vous sentir très
bien mais on a inventé des
convertisseurs dont vous on sait
convertir chez vous de l'énergie d'un
morceau de poisson ou d'une frite pas
votre pour la santé trop gras du reste
mais et vous allez réussir à transformer
ça en mouvement pas très rapide 20 km
heure au maximum
on a découvert des convertisseurs qu'ils
savaient faire beaucoup mieux que ça et
c'est l'essor de ces convertisseurs
qu'on fait la civilisation industrielle
il les sort de ces convertisseurs nous a
permis depuis maintenant deux siècles de
renverser le raisonnement
multimillénaire ou de renverser la
hiérarchie multimillénaire entre la
contrainte environnementale et nos
désirs car jusqu'à cette époque là
l'univers était férocement contre un par
les capacités va pas donc la nature et
est hostile
l'homme était limitée dans sa capacité
d'action et donc la façon dont on avait
la façon qu'on avait à l'époque par don
de voir notre rapport au monde et notre
rapport à l'avenir c'était d'être
fataliste les contraintes sont ce
qu'elles sont la puissance de ma maigre
carcasse ne me permet pas de les
transgresser
donc je me protège du mieux que je peux
je survis du mieux que je peux j'avance
du mieux que je peux et la limite que je
cherche à transgresser je la laisse très
très modeste donc voilà donc monsieur
quartier il va découvrir le cada
magellan le détroit qui porte son nom
c'est le fait d'une poignée d'hommes la
mise en service de ces convertisseurs a
permis à chacun d'entre nous de dompter
des centaines d'esclaves mécanique et on
s'est dit on a renversé le raisonnement
c'est qu'on a cessé d'être fataliste on
s'est dit quels que soient mes désirs je
serai capable de les mettre en oeuvre
effectivement on avait la puissance
mécanique pour ce pour ce faire donc on
s'est dit on va chauffer tout le monde
pas de problème mais une chaudière j'ai
tout le monde on va déplacer son qui
doivent à tout le monde à 100 km/heure
pas de problème on met une voiture chez
tout le monde
on va manger à notre faim pas de
problème on met des usines d'engrais
détracteurs au travail
on va vivre vieux pas de problème on met
en place un système de prophylaxie
d'adduction d'eau parce qu'il faut bien
voir que ce qui a fait l'espérance de
vie
c'est très très peu la médecine curative
et énormément
la prévention c'est l'alimentation et
l'hygiène qui ont fait donc l'adduction
d'eau potable et l'évacuation des étrons
loin des villes c'est ça qui a fait la
banque entend laver les cadavres et la
fosse à purin juste à côté du puits
c'était pas terrible en tout cas ça
réguler plus les populations ça c'est
clairement
donc le concept abstrait des mécanismes
de régulation grâce à l'énergie et du
coup on a renversé le raisonnement entre
les les frontières naturelles du monde
et nos désirs
avant on cale et nos désirs sur les
frontières du monde et maintenant on a
calé nos les frontières du monde sur nos
désirs et qu'elle est les frontières du
monde sur nos désirs
c'est le rêve techniciste c'est le rêve
que quelles que soient nos désirs de
toute façon la technologie permettra de
satisfaire points et donc les riches qui
vient ils sont dans cette logique là
c'est à dire pour eux la croissance
perpétuelle et le fait qu'elle soit
verte ça pose pas de problème la
technique va sauver tout le monde est
cette logique là est particulièrement
vrai aux états unis pour une raison
assez simple c'est que c'était de end of
plenty
donc c'était l'incarnation ultime du
monde plein de ressources où il suffit
de désiré pour avoir ce à quoi ça sert à
quoi on aspire et donc c'est pas
étonnant que le rêve techniciste
viennent des états unis
et c'est pas étonnant que les systèmes
plus fataliste il ya eu contrainte faut
l'accepter viennent des pays qui sont
historiques dans le dans le peuplement
du monde c'est à dire l'europe et la
chine et le japon
c'est à dire des endroits où il ya des
vieilles civilisations qui elles ont eu
plusieurs fois l'occasion d'être
meurtris dans leur chair par des famines
par des maladies et donc qu'ils savent
que la fatalité ça existe et qui sont
culturellement un peu plus enclines à
s'en occuper et au sein de ces pays
si vous regardez les pays les plus les
plus allants sur la capacité à se
satisfaire des limites du monde sont les
pays qui ont été les plus contraints de
ces ensembles là et en europe c'est pour
continuer dans ce raisonnement c'est les
pays insulaires la grande bretagne les
pays nordiques parce que l'hiver suédois
il ya un siècle il fallait se plaît il
n'y avait pas de chauffage central rien
à bouffer cultiver du blé en hiver en
suède c'est quand même compliqué et la
suisse faut quand même rappeler que le
suisse était avant guerre l'européen le
plus pauvre
paysans suisses c'était une vie de
misère par rapport à nos standards
actuels
et donc ce n'est pas étonnant que ce
soit ces pays qui aujourd'hui est le
plus le sens du collectif et le plus la
culture du long terme
ils ont été le plus marqués dans leur
chair par la contrainte environnementale
et c'est pour ça que les anglais sont
fatalistes et qu'ils ont et qui sont
dures à la peine et dur au mal qu'on
leur connaît cette aptitude à être dur à
la peine mais il ya une raison
historique à ça donc pour finir sur ce
long selon couple est notre plus grand
problème si on veut se confronter à la
limite du monde s'appelle les états unis
[Musique]
non ça va pas être simple et donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut savoir leur
résister et au lieu d'arrêter de les
suivre comme des béni-oui-oui a très
bien parti pour non vous avez lu le
livre de pablo servi né à falaise comme
tout peut s'effondrer
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé et
notamment de l'avant la partie constat
je pense qu'elle était là il ya une
partie qui est plus sur la psychologie
de l'effondrement qui est assez
intéressante me semble qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé qu est-ce qu on se
rassure la psychologie de l'effondrement
très honnêtement je n'ai pas appris
grand chose non plus parce qu'aux gros
en gros il explique que l'on passe par
les cinq phases classiques du voilà du
déni du deuil du machin etc
je crois sauf erreur de ma part que dans
le plein s'il vous plaît on avait dit
exactement la même chose
par contre 2006 par contre ce que j'ai
trouvé très intéressant dans leur
bouquin c'est leur capacité à argumenter
sur le fait que la résilience n'était
pas une affaire de capacités
individuelles mais une affaire de
capacité collective
dit autrement que le sist qu'on devient
résilient quand on arrive à se
constituer un réseau d'entre aide qui va
permettre de ne pas devoir compter que
sur ses forces propres pour faire face à
l'adversité voilà ça j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant l'argumentation qui va
derrière ça donc en gros ils combattent
le mythe du du fermi américain en terré
dans son bunker avec 200 joueurs de
vivre
le fusil qu'à 34 cas 30 cartouches
l'abri antiatomique etc et capable de
résister à tout ce qui lui tombe dessus
il argumente le fait que c'est le le le
sens du collectif et la coopération
voilà exactement séduisant de fonds à
laquelle on a envie de se rattacher en
tout cas quand tout est dit et en plus
cela non mais surtout moi j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant parce qu'en fait quand j'ai
réfléchi bien ça correspond à une
réalité déjà du coup est-ce que vous
préparer à vivre différemment dans un
futur plus ou moins proche
alors moi je me prépare à vivre
différemment au sens de jeu suis
psychologiquement un peu plus préparés
qu'avant à ce qui se passe des choses
désagréables tente il faudra qu'il
faudra être à moitié surpris il ya des
choses auxquelles je suis toujours pas
préparé par exemple la privation de
liberté qui est un truc qui nous pend au
nez
parce que la démocratie c'est aussi un
truc que j'explique dans mon dernier
bouquin pour moi elle est compliqué à
maintenir sans croissance
en fait les démocraties sont apparus
dans les régiments croissance le régime
qui est le premier à entrer en
croissance en or dans l'europe post
médiévale c'est la grande bretagne et
c'est le premier endroit où la
démocratie est apparue donc maintenir la
démocratie
j'explique pourquoi dans mon bouquin
dans un monde sans croissance pense que
ça va être dur
et donc si on suit la logique jusqu'au
bout
plus de démocratie ça veut dire que les
libertés individuelles sont restreintes
ça très honnêtement par exemple c'est un
truc dont j'ai pas encore totalement
fait mon deuil
sur d'autres sujets le fait que l'on va
un peu plus souple et l'hiver pour ce
qui restera de l'hiver et c'est non mais
je veux dire je sais que c'est ça qui
nous attend le fait que les transports
en commun vont voir leur qualité de
service se dégrader
pour des raisons de contraintes
économiques tient sans croissance ils
n'ont pas plus de moyens
par contre sans croissance il ya plus en
plus de gens n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer de bagnols et qui veulent s'en
servir
donc il va y avoir un moment un
antagonisme entre la quantité de gens
qui veulent y avoir droit et les
ressources pour faire fonctionner le
truc je m'y attends bon donc quand les
gens gueulent sur le quai du rer parce
qu'il a dix minutes de retard moi je
gueule pas du tout là dessus je suis
devenu très fataliste et je me dis il
faut juste s'organiser en conséquence
on part avec un bouquin et puis si 7h10
de plus bas ça dure dix minutes de plus
et puis voilà donc il ya un certain
nombre de sujets sur lequel je suis déjà
là il ya d'autres sujets individuels par
exemple l'endroit où j'habite les la
performance thermique de la maison etc
ou là je suis pas encore en ligne avec
ce que je devrais faire mais je suis
tombé sur un problème que énormément de
gens connaissent dès lors qu'ils ont une
cellule familiale qui est que la prise
en compte de ce problème dans une
cellule familiale elle et hydrogène tout
le monde n'accepte pas d'aller à la même
vitesse sur la prise en compte de ce
problème et les conséquences qu'il faut
en tirer
or une décision par exemple sur le
logement est nécessairement une décision
collégiale si vous êtes en couple vous
n'allez pas imposer à votre conjoint le
choix d'une chaudière alors que lui ai
dit je suis contre
non mais ça n'existe pas soit d'une
nouvelle destination ni le choix des
nouvelles d'un logo liés aux habillages
je veux dire l'achat d'un logement pour
ceux qui ont les moyens d'acheter un
logement c'est quand même l'achat le
plus important que dit donc donc cesser
voilà donc le une des difficultés dans
la progression des gens qui ne sont pas
seuls alors ça fait rigoler parce que
beaucoup de gens qui s'intéressent à ce
sujet sont jeunes
donc ils sont pas encore lié par des
obligations familiales
même s'ils sont en couple c'est plus ça
se défait plus facilement
que plus tard qu'il ya des enfants ils
n'ont pas d'enfants dont ils ont ils ont
ils n'ont pas la conscience aiguë du
fait que c'est difficile de changer
même quand vous en avez envie mais que
c'est pas homogène au sein de votre
cellule familiale
voilà qu'en pour la 50e fois vous
revenez du marché en ailleurs ramené du
poulet et que votre conjoint vous dis
j'en ai marre j'en ai mangé du boeuf non
mais vous faites quoi est ce que vous
faites donc les jeunes ils voient pas ça
et même motif même punition quand dans
le salon il fait 19 degrés et que votre
conjoint ou dit tu fais chier avec tes
conneries
moi je vois qu'ils fassent 20 ou 21 fait
quoi bon et puis pour ceux qui en ont
encore les moyens pour ceux qui ont
encore les moyens quand votre conjoint
oui moi j'ai envie d'aller au canada et
oui il a raison il faut prendre l'avion
donc moi j'ai pas envie fait quoi donc
voilà donc il ya plein voilà alors moi
j'ai pas envie oui mais machin et
machines ils sont allés c'est
dégueulasse donc tous ces sujets là sont
des sujets qui sont pas du tout
anecdotique et aujourd'hui soit dit en
passant je n'ai jamais vu de sociologues
de psychologues s'intéresser à ce que
moi je crois être un sujet absolument
central pour que cette préoccupation se
convertissent plus vite en acte qui est
c'est quoi la façon de faire avancer ce
genre de sujet au sein d'une cellule
familiale où la motivation de départ et
inhomogène moi j'aimerais bien qu'il y
ait des gens qui bossent un peu sur la
question parce qu'à mon avis c'est un
des freins majeurs à l'action l'histoire
économique vient derrière un avis non
mais la question de la norme sociale
c'est à dire ce à quoi on considère
qu'on a droit ou pas droit
c'est beaucoup plus puissant à mon avis
je relis et si ma femme pense qu'elle a
droit de manger du boeuf c'est pas une
affaire d'économie et lire les gens qui
sont encore assez riche pour s'acheter
un pot-au-feu ou un steak haché
certainement
son de raisonnement est d'accord mais
comme on y arrive c'est quoi les trucs
et astuces
c'est quoi la façon de travailler là
dessus c'est quoi les discours c'est
quoi les etc
je me rappelle qu'à l'époque j'avais à
l'époque où j'étais proche de la
fondation ex nicolas hulot équivalent
cervelle pour la nature et l'homme je
leur avais suggéré de travailler sur
deux sujets qui étaient faire en sorte
que les jeunes couples retourne au
marché plutôt que d'aller au supermarché
alors ça peut paraître tout con mais
quand vous allez au marché
vous participez à un système où
globalement vous avez une bien meilleure
gestion des stocks
parce que le commerçant chez qui vous
arrive et vous aviez l'idée d'acheter
des oranges ou diva je suis désolé j'ai
plus d'orange vous les travaux de
mandarine pas vous repartez que des
mandarines et vous allez chez le
volailler vous aviez l'intention
d'acheter un poulet il dit j'ai pu de
poulet mais j'ai un très bon canard
l'avant donc qu'ils ont une bien
meilleure gestion de leurs stocks
et ça je le sais pour avoir discuté avec
des poissonniers par exemple je sais que
le taux de déchets des poissons en
grandes surfaces et chez les commerçants
du marché ont rien à voir il ya un ordre
de grandeur de différence entre les deux
donc voilà vous allez avoir une aptitude
à vous remettre à faire la cuisine qui
est plus importante
et donc vous allez aussi participé à des
systèmes qui sont globalement plus sobre
sur le plan à la fois du gaspillage de
talent moins d'emballage moins de
logistique
vingt ans que je suis en train de dire
ça fait pas les affaires des gens de
l'agroalimentaire et les grandes
surfaces mais on s'en fout dans un souk
ppr a toujours dit qu'ils avaient une
partie des gens qui permet moi ça me va
bien
bon voilà effet l'âge ça l'a jamais
intéressé et j'avais un deuxième sujet
dont je leur avais parlé qui était
exactement celui là c'est à dire comment
faire pour que au sein d'une cellule
familiale où il ya un couple et des
enfants
ce sujet-là avançant que ce soit une
pomme de discorde ça n'est jamais
intéressé non plus je reste persuadé
qu'en termes de psychologie
ces deux trucs cool ces deux points durs
absolument cruciaux et que si on sait
pas traiter ces problèmes là il ya plein
de trucs qu'on n'ira nulle part
le discours incantatoires pourrait faire
tous les discours incantatoires que vous
voulez sur le logement mais si la
cellule familiale est pas d'accord sur
ce qu'on fait sur le logement il se
passera strictement rien
rien un jour j'avais demandé toujours
une anecdote au patron de la fédération
française du bâtiment qui par ailleurs
est promoteur immobilier j'ai une
question
quand vous voyez arriver et donc j'ai un
sujet fin quand vous voyez arriver un
couple qui envisagent d'acheter un
logement et que l'homme et la femme sont
pas d'accord c'est quoi la proportion
des cas de figure où c'est l'homme qui a
le dernier mot
le mec éclate de rire il va de zéro donc
la femme a un droit de veto sur
l'endroit où il y aura la cellule
familiale parce que c'est elle qui a le
lead sur le fait que les enfants doivent
aller dans une bonne école c'est elle
qui a le lead sur la gestion logistique
de la bouffe où on ira faire les courses
jusqu'ici elle avait le livre j'espère
que c'est en train de se nom est là le
lit de en termes d'ascendant c'est pas
nécessairement elle qui va faire les
courses
mais c'est elle qui aura le dernier mot
sur le fait qu'elle a envie que les
courses soient faites ici plutôt que là
c'est ça que je veux dire et c'est
souvent elle qui a le lead sur
l'organisation interne du logement sur
le fait que la chambre des gamins sera
ici plutôt que là que etc et je suis pas
en train de dire que c'est bien ou c'est
mal vu
moi je la différenciation des sexes la
biologie dit qu'on n'est pas constitue
exactement pareil donc le fait qu'on
n'ait pas des modes de raisonnement
exactement identique ça me paraît non
seulement normal mais celle inverse qui
me paraît très bizarre donc le donc le
donc il ya un sujet femme aussi dans
cette histoire et et tant mieux je leur
dis c'est pas du sexisme de dire ça la
façon dont une femme va prendre un
problème c'est pas la façon dont un
homme va prendre un problème
bon c'est pas pareil donc il ya des il
ya des vrais sujets qui sont liées à la
psychologie humaine dans la façon
d'avancer et je suis je trouve dommage
aujourd'hui que ça n'avance pas et c est
pour finir de répondre très longuement à
la question sur le technicisme le
technicisme est une affaire d'hommes le
côté rifkin ya la technique va nous
sauver c'est quand même un discours très
masculin non c'est le rêve de gamin
c'est le rêve de gamin et ses petites
voitures
oui c'est aussi un discours de
domination on est d'accord mais on est
d'accord c'est un discours de
transgression les hommes sont plus
transgressifs la testostérone ça les
pousse à faire plus ce genre de trucs
donc il ya et le discours féminin qui
est quand même globalement plus un
discours de douceur et parra s'est ancré
dans la façon d'avancer dans ce genre de
sujet donc effectivement l'homme il a
really bouscule tout et il s'impose et
le rêve techniciste participe de ça et
évidemment comme il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'hommes dans les postes de direction
dans les boîtes tout ça boucle donc il
ya énormément de grandes entreprises
voilà c'est pas très étonnant donc une
des raisons pour lesquelles moi je suis
favorable à ce qui est plus de femmes
dans les instances dirigeantes des
entreprises c'est ça c'est pas pour une
raison d'égalité homme femme parce que
non je m'en fous sincèrement au sens de
je pense aujourd'hui qu'on est arrivé à
un état de maturité de la société ou une
femme qui a vraiment envie
elle fait ses preuves et elle avance
enfin je veux dire il ya quand même des
grosses discrimination madame lagarde
elle avait vraiment envie aller patronne
du fonds monétaire international 1 kolda
meyer avait vraiment envie elle a dirigé
l'état israélien enfin je veux dire je
n'achète pas ce que je crois par contre
c'est qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'univers dans lequel pour avancer il
faut devenir brutale et que c'est pas
dans la nature des femmes d'être brutal
est tant mieux
voilà donc une des raisons par exemple
pour lesquelles il y en a pas en dans
les hautes sphères politiques
c'est parce que être arrivé dans les
hautes sphères politiques c'est un
parcours de brut et ça correspond pas à
l'essentiel de la psychologie féminine
bon il sans donner de nom un certain
nombre de femmes politiques qui sont
devenus très visible c'est les hommes en
jupe 1 et dans certaines grandes
entreprises aussi donc il ya des il ya
des c'est pas une bonne idée qu elle
c'est le seul modèle comme elsa pose
quand même d'accord toute chose c'est
pas une bonne idée qu'elle imite les
hommes faut qu'elle soit différente
complémentaires et en harmonie est pas
identique sinon ça sert à rien d'en
avoir
si on est un peu idiot dans le
raisonnement voilà donc il ya un vrai
côté je le redis psychologie à
travailler pour qu'on se sorte de ce
rêve techniciste et qu'on arrive à
transformer et qu'on arrive à faire
percolé l'action individuelle dans les
cellules familiales ce qu'aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup de mal à faire à cause de ça
à cause du fait que le l'envi de départ
les gens sont pas alignés et alors pour
conclure at est ce que vous pensez qu'il
ya encore de la place pour l'optimisme
était déjà de cette question mais ce
n'est pas l'optimisme de l'action reste
qu est-ce qu on peut la retrouver du
sens il faut assez si on ne retrouve pas
de sens on est foutu c'est plutôt ça le
sujet en fait qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
donner comme raison d'avoir envie de se
lever le matin à des gens à qui vous
n'allez plus pouvoir donner ce qui était
la base du contrat social depuis deux
siècles sert de plus en plus de pognon a
du sens
et rien d'autre et aujourd'hui ce que
vous voyez alors à petite dose vous
voyez des gens qui ont fait ce choix
c'est souvent des gens qui sont au
dessus du seuil de survie qui ont fait
ce choix mais qui ont fait le choix
d'abandonner de l'argent pour un métier
où il ya plus de sens
moi j'ai jamais cru une seule seconde
que les hommes n'étaient que des agents
économiques rationnelle maximisant leur
revenu je sais pas pourquoi on continue
à enseigner cette connerie sans nom en
cours d'économie
les hommes sont des êtres obéissant à
des normes sociales et la maximisation
des revenus ça va derrière
si tous les gens chercher à maximiser
leurs revenus vous auriez pu un seul
chercheur aujourd'hui dans ce pays parce
que si pas d'enseignants pas de
chercheurs pas de prêtre personne qui
fait de l'engagement associatif etc
donc c'est une connerie de raconter
enfin je veux dire c'est juste bon le
seul cours auquel une de mes filles
moins de la moyenne
récemment c'était le cours de
macroéconomie joyal j'en ai pas voulu
n'importe quoi d'autre d'un peu
rigoureux scientifiquement j'aurais dit
là vraiment je suis pas content là là je
me suis dit plus
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle et c'est
évident qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont
prêts à gagner moins d'argent pour plus
de sens plein plein plein plein plein
alors ce qui est tout aussi évident
c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'offre n'existe
pas c'est donc les gens parfois ils
s'inventent leurs propres offres
donc moi je connais plusieurs personnes
qui aujourd'hui vivent matériellement et
économiquement moins bien qu'avant en
ayant fait un retour à la terre il ya
plein de cadre urbain aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont se mettre à la permaculture au
maraîchage de proximité etc
j'en connais plein à commencer par le
producteur bio que bon marché qui était
cadre c'est chez syngenta
bon alors il était un peu aidé par le
fait que ses parents avaient une
exploitation fleuve avait déjà une
exploitation maraîchère qui la reprise
qui la convertit en bio
et voilà ça marche très bien je connais
un ancien cadre dirigeant de chez j
power donc maintenant de chez alstom
power donc maintenant dj pareil alors
séparé il avait des terres familiales
mais aujourd'hui les gentlemen farmer
par ailleurs conversion en bio
et c'est encore un autre il était dit et
éthicien est prof de karaté à la ville
il est devenu m'arracher en traction
animale
non mais donc est le dernier en date
c'est quelqu'un je connais qui était
ingénieur chez areva et il est parti
faire la permaculture au bec hellouin
donc le donc le donc ça existe déjà des
gens qui refusent
gaël giraud il est père jésuite donc
tout ce qu'ils gagnent ils lui versent à
sa communauté il doit être payé jeu
pourront bien au smic
bon bref donc il ya ça existe déjà des
gens qui ont troqué le sens et même moi
qui gagne très bien ma vie je la gagne 5
fois moins bien que si j'avais fait
comme une partie de mes copains de trop
qui sont devenus cadres dirigeants dans
des entreprises à droite et à gauche et
qui est aujourd'hui entre leurs salaires
les stock options j'ai pas quoi gagner
n'importe quoi entre cinq et dix fois ce
que je gagne et je ne les envie pas je
veux dire je ne suis pas là tous les
jours à me dire je suis jaloux et cetera
je fais un boulot dans lé que je
m'éclate donc donc donc ça mais je reste
très bien payés par rapport à la moyenne
et français donc je pas en train de dire
que j'ai fait un essai pas c'est un
sacrifice qui reste très très tolérable
donc le mais c'est juste pour dire le la
possibilité d'avoir moins là où le
raisonnement s'arrête c'est quand le
moins vous entame vos besoins vitaux
donc accepter d'avoir moins quand vous
avez plus du tout de toi ou à bouffer là
ça devient compliqué mais on en est
encore très loin parce que le logement
c'est 30 % si on gagne et la bouffe
c'est 2% du pib
d'accord donc mis bout-à-bout un tiers
de nos revenus correspond à des désirs
vitaux à des besoins vitaux
tout le reste c'est du désir solvable
donc ya de la marge
y compris chez des gens qu'on a coutume
de qualifier de modestes et qui au
regard de ce qui était un paysan du
moyen-âge sont déjà immensément riche
le smicard français est immensément
riche au regard d'un paysan du moyen-âge
ya juste elle lui sinon c'était aussi
l'introduction d'un de mes bouquins on
aurait dit à un paysan du moyen-âge dans
dedans dans trois siècles
enfin il viendra un jour pour être plus
précis où les gens vivront en moyenne
trois fois plus longtemps que toi où ils
n'auront jamais faim où ils pourront
manger de la viande quasiment à tous les
repas où ils pourront se déplacer à 100
km heure
d'une simple pression du pied où ils
auront chaud l'hiver parce que tous les
smicards
en général il vit dans un endroit qui
est chauffée l'hiver même pas bien ils
auront encore leurs dents à 50 ans etc
on aurait dit ça un paysan gardé comme
un martien où comme un fou mais contre
quoi
c'est la réalité d'aujourd'hui et on a
les jeux du cirque dans notre salon
s'appelle la télévision et on a failli
dire c'est sait il faut il faut voir en
pratique ce que c'était que la vie d'un
pays à la paix ils ont envoyé nagy
sortait jamais de sa ferme
il avait toute sa vie il faisait 5 km
autour de son domicile
à 30 ans il ya moitié de ses dents
qu'elle ait disparu non mais ils
dormaient l'heure un seul lit où il
baisse des denrées avec ces gars
inférieur c'est dur est de temps en
temps il avait un qui advient kiki qui
étaient ils rouillés pendant la nuit
parce qu'on lui dormait dessus non mais
il faut voir
on n'a pas conscience moi donc entre ses
comptes cette condition là qui a été la
condition multimillénaire de l'homme est
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui moi je le redis
si on a vraiment envie de retrouver du
sens et de la marge par contre le
problème et j'en reviens c'est toujours
pareil c'est comment est ce qu'on arrive
dans un univers de choix parce que la
démocratie c'est l'univers du choix
a entraîné une masse critique de gens
dans un sens partagé ça c'est pareil
c'est un truc qui aujourd'hui personne
n'a trouvé de la solution à cette
équation
les quelques fois où ça arrive c'est en
général des projets un peu violent mais
mes courbes avancer encore un ca reste
un problème non résolu mais le c'est
aussi un des deux gardiens du sujet
c'est c'est d'arriver à entraîner une
fraction critique au sens physique du
terme au sens de qui déclenché la
réaction vers un projet commun qui est
susceptible de parler à une majorité de
la population
un de mes regrets pour finir là-dessus
parce que faut pas dire du mal des
politiques dans ce pays c'est que je
pense que ma kron avait pas encore mais
plus pour longtemps un boulevard sur ce
terrain là et que pour le moment il ne
sait pas s'en emparer alors il est
peut-être mal conseillé stupide pas
assez fort mais je ne sais pas mais il
n'a pas compris que c'était
à mon avis une de ses planches de salut
parce que parce que faire repartir le
système de manière conventionnelle n'est
pas à sa portée pendant agents physiques
tout cas je suis bien curieuse de voir
ce que l'avenir nous réserve
merci beaucoup merci merci à jean marc
jancovici pour cette conversation
présage est un podcast indépendant le
générique est un extrait du morceau lot
de sabrina belahouel mixé par paloma
colombes
si vous voulez soutenir présage le mieux
est de mettre cinq étoiles sur itunes
vous pouvez aussi partager les épisodes
les commentaires vous inscrire à la
newsletter sur le site présage
plurielles.fr l'occasion aussi de
retrouver des liens et des ressources
pour approfondir les différents sujets
évoqués a très vite
[Musique]